en nagorno karabaj es una región de
azerbaiján autoproclamada independiente
poblada principalmente por armenios y
apoyada por armenia l fue escenario de
una guerra a principios de los años 90
en la que murieron 30.000 personas desde
entonces las autoridades azerbaiyanas
han tratado de recuperar el control de
la misma aunque en 1994 se acordó una
sensación del fuego
azerbaiyán y armenia se acusan con
frecuencia de ataques alrededor de
nagorno karabaj y a lo largo de la
frontera que les separa en 2016 unos
graves enfrentamientos donde murieron
más de 200 personas ya habían estado a
punto de degenerar en una guerra en
julio de 2020 también se produjeron
combates mortales entre armenios y
azerbaiyanos en su frontera que dejó al
menos 16 víctimas
bakú aprovechó sus enormes reservas de
petróleo para gastar generosamente en
armamento azerbayán también puede contar
con el apoyo del presidente turco que
considera a armenia como una amenaza
para la estabilidad del cáucaso armenia
por otro lado es mucho más pobre y está
más cerca de rusia que tiene una base
militar allí
ereván también pertenece a una alianza
político militar liderada por moscú la
organización del tratado de seguridad
colectiva el conflicto ha preocupado a
los países occidentales y regionales en
parte porque podría causar inestabilidad
en el cáucaso meridional que sirve de
corredor para los oleoductos y
gasoductos que transportan petróleo y
gas a los mercados mundiales el kremlin
que se posiciona como árbitro regional
entrega armas a ambos países